مشاهدينا اهلا بكم شكرا لاحمد والساعه
الاخباريه مستمره انا ميسون عزام احييكم
ونخصص هذه الساعه ايضا لتغطيه التطورات في
السودان ومشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
اشتباكات متقطعه وحياه شبه طبيعيه في
الخرطوم وام درمان وحصيله قتل المدنيين
تتجاوز 440
مبعوث البرهان يؤكد من القاهره على ترتيب
عمليه سياسيه شامله بعد انتهاء الازمه في
السودان
وفي هذه النشره ايضا
[موسيقى]
قصف اسرائيلي فلسطيني متبادل 20 صاروخا
اطلقت من غزه واخرى عليها
كيف تستعد للهجوم المضاد وروسيا تؤكد ان
اوكرانيا فقدت 15 الف جندي خلال الشهر
الماضي
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا مع استمرار خرق الهدن
المعلنه منذ بدء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع كشفت نقابه اطباء السودان
عن سقوط
477 قتيلا والفين وخمسه وخمسين مصابا من
المدنيين طبعا منذ بدء الاشتباكات في
الخامسه عشر من ابريل الماضي باتت الاوضاع
الطبيه في تفاقم مستمر خرجت عشرات
المستشفيات عن الخدمه فيما باتت المخازن
الطبيه فارغه في بعض الولايات ومع هذا
الوضع لم يجد السودانيون الى النزوح سبيلا
حيث قالت الامم المتحده ان حوالي نصف
مليون سوداني فرو داخليا وخارجيا وذلك منذ
منتصف ابريل الماضي ويعاني اخرون ممن
قرروا البقاء من ابسط الخدمات الاساسيه من
غذاء ومياه وايضا كهرباء فيما يبقى عزيز
الرصاص مسموعا وان كان بشكل متقطع
[موسيقى]
كل المراك
بحاجه الحرب الدائره الان نحن برامج ظروف
خاصه
نعمل بهذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم امكانيات
اللي ما موجوده
بعض الادويه والمعدات
انس
انيه مما يتعلق بالتطورات الميدانيه فقط
قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها قالت
انها اسقطت الطائره من طراز ميك تابعه
طبعا للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم ذكرت قوات
الدعم السريع انها تصدت لغارات عده شنها
الجيش السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق
سكنيه بالخرطوم
هذا واظهرت الصور استهداف طيران الجيش
السوداني لاهداف وايضا تمركزات تابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا ورغم الهدنه المعلنه افاد مراسل
العربيه في السودان عن سماع عدوي اسلحه
ثقيله للاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في منطقه المهندسين
بامدرمان حيث حلق طيران الجيش السوداني في
مدن الخرطوم الثلاث واستهدف مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع المراسل اكد على استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم في
منطقه كفوري بالخرطوم بحري فيما شن طيران
الجيش السوداني قصفا جويا في ولايه شرق
النيل بحسب المراسل ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلنت
فيه سلطات الطيران المدني السوداني تمديد
اغلاق المجال الجوي باستثنائي طائرات
الاجلاء والمساعدات
ونتابع معكم هذا الفيديو الذي يوثق
استمرار الاشتباكات بمناطق حيويه في
العاصمه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من الخرطوم الصحفي عمار ابو
شيبه اهلا بك استاذ عمار بدايه اخر
التطورات والمعلومات المتوفره لديك حول
الوضع الميداني
نعم ميسون يعني ما زلنا في هذه الساعه وفي
هذه الدقائق نستمع الى طائرات التحليق
التي هي في سماع العاصمه الخرطوم وفي وسط
العاصمه ومن خلال هذه المنطقه الشرقيه في
منطقه شرق العاصمه الخرطوم تحليق الطيران
مازال مستمرا منذ الساعه الماضيه وحتى هذه
الساعه هنالك التحليق كثيف جدا لطائرات
الاستطلاع وقبل الساعه من الان كان هناك
ايضا تحليق للمقاتلات الحربيه في سماع
العاصمه الخرطوم وبحسب مصادر تحدثنا اليها
ومعلومات وردت الينا بين بان هذه الطائرات
كانت قد نفذت ربما اهدافا عسكريه دمرت هذه
الاهداف في مدينه ام درمان والان دائما ما
نتعود في مثلها كذا ساعات ونستمع فيها الى
الطائرات الجو هي تحلق في سماء الخرطوم
ونستمع
للمضادات الارضيه لقوات الدعم السريع
والتي لم تصب هذه الطائرات ولكن ما زالت
المضادات تعمل وما زالت الطائرات تحلق في
سماع العاصمه الخرطوم طائره واحده سيد
عمار عمار في راس لطائره واحده تم اسقاطها
بحسب الدعم السريع
نعم يعني اكثر من طائره رصدناها من خلال
هذه الساعه المعروفه ان طائرات الاستطلاع
تاتي ومن ثم تعقبها الطائرات المقاتلات
الحربيه والتي تنفذ طلعات جويه لتدمير
اهداف على الارض هذا ما نشاهده من خلال
هذه الدقائق يعني ونلاحظ ايضا كذلك سماع
لعدد من الانفجارات في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وعدد من الحرائق ربما باتجاه
مدينه بحري ما زالت اعمده الدخان تتصاعد
من تلك المناطق وما زال الطيران يحلق
بكثافه في هذه المناطق مع معلومات ميدانيه
بان هنالك اشتباكات ايضا على الارض وربما
هي اشتباكات متقطعه ومناوشات ما بين فرقه
تمشيط وما بين المناطق التي تتحصن فيها
وتتمركز فيها قوات الدعم هذه التطورات هل
لا زلنا نرصد عمليات نزوح او لا خفت
نعم هنالك عمليات خروج ما زلنا نلاحظ تلك
العمليات من خلال كثير جدا من السفريات من
محطات السفر التي رصدناها وتابعنا عمليات
اجلاء للكثيرين في تلك المناطق وخاصه من
الرعايه الاجانب بشكل كبير على مستوى
المواطنين هنالك من خرجوا من هذه المناطق
مناطق العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها ثلاث
واتجهوا الى مناطق اكثر امنا واتجهوا ايضا
باتجاه الولايات الشماليه والشرقيه
والحديث هنا ايضا يدور عن ربما عمليات نهب
وسلب لمن للذين غادروا منازلهم بشكل الذين
متواجدين داخل هذه المنازل هنالك كثير من
المعلومات تحدثوا عنها ونشروا تلك الصور
والفيديوهات لعمليات سلب ونهب تدور في تلك
المناطق هذا الخروج للمناطق الامنه ربما
هو بداعي الاشتباكات العسكريه في هذه
اللحظه نستمع الى الطيران الحربي الذي نفذ
طلعات جويه في منطقه وسط الخرطوم نلاحظ
انفجارات في تلك المنطقه وما زالت
المضادات ترد وربما هنالك طلعات جويه
قادمه بحكم ان هذه الاوقات دائما ما تكسر
فيها طلعات الجويه وتستهدف اهدافا على
الارض استمعنا قبل ثواني من الان الى هذا
الانفجار والذي نفذته طائرات حربيه في
منطقه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم اعمار كونك
تحدثنا عمليات النهب بالشرطه من المفترض
انها انتشرت في عدد من المناطق هل تتمركز
في مناطق دون غيرها وبالمقابل تاثير هذا
الانتشار باختصار
نعم هذه الشرطه والمعروف عنها بفرقه
الاحتياط المركزي تمركزت بشكل واضح
وانتشرت في مدينه ام درمان في عدد من
المناطق التي ينفتح فيها الجيش اما في
المناطق الاخرى والتي تتمركز فيها وتتحصن
فيها قوات الدعم السريع لم نلاحظ انتشار
لقوات الاحتياطي المركزي التابعه للشرطه
السودانيه وفي المناطق التي انتشرت فيها
تلك القوات هنالك مواطنين كثر تحدثوا
الينا بانهم يعني لم يشاهدوا عملياتنا
توقفت هذه العمليات نسبه لانتشار هذه
القوات في تلك المناطق وهي مناطق يسيطر
عليها الجيش وانفتح في كثير جدا من
شوارعها اتحدث هنا عن مدينه ام درمان
الشماليه بشكل واضح وكبير اما المناطق
التي ما زالت تتواجد فيها قوات الدعم
السريع لم تنتشر تلك القوات فيها باعتبار
ان هذه المناطق مناطق اشتباك من الدرجه
الاولى ومواجهه مباشره خاصه محيط الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بمدينه القديمه وعدد من
الشوارع الفرعيه
ابو شيبه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
تحركنا من يوم الارض من خرطوم فكان يعني
صعبه جدا
ويتحركنا عدد احنا 28
والاولاد يعني ما عندهم تاشيره وخليناهم
الان ومتحركين احنا طلعنا من تحت الادانات
من تحت الضرب وطلعنا من يعني طلعنا من
الاجوبه بتاعته والضرب لحد ما حصلنا
بيان لقوات الدعم السريعه قد اتهم الجيش
بالتسبب في مقتل وجرح العشرات من
المواطنين بعد قصف مستشفى شرقي النيل
بالطيران الحربي اوضحت قوات الدعم السريعه
عبر حسابها على تويتر ان القصف بالطيران
شمل مستشفى شرق النيل الى جانب عدد من
المصانع بالمنطقه الصناعيه بحري وعدد من
المنشات المدنيه والطبيه والعسكريه
متحده تتدخل تشوف امر لحمتني ولا البرهان
[موسيقى]
وفي محاوله لمواجهه حاله الانفلات
المستمره جراء الاشتباكات اعلنت الشرطه
السودانيه الدفع بتعزيزات امنيه لتامين
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه والاحياء كما
اشارت الشرطه الى قيامها بحملات خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه في عدد من مناطق
جنوب الخرطوم بمشاركته وتنسيق امني مشترك
مع القوات المسلحه
ونشاهد خارجيه جنوب السودان البرهان
وحميتي وفقا مبدئيا على هدنه لمده سبعه
ايام تبدا من الرابع من مايو اي يوم
الخميس على كل نحن نتحدث عن هدنه هشه طبعا
تخللها عدد من الاشتباكات والقصف ونامل
الان بهدنه جديده تمديد اذا لهذه الهدن
التي بدات منذ فتره هذه هي خامس هدنه
والان نتحدث عن هدنه سادسه من اقليم
دارفور ينضم الينا الصحفي صالح ابو علامه
اهلا بك
صالح بدايه هل لك ان تعطينا فكره عن اخر
التطورات الميدانيه تحديدا في اقليم
دارفور هل بالفعل هدت الامور قبائليا
اعمل الامور في غرب دارفور الجنينه هنالك
هدوء يسود الان ارجاء المدينه بعد التوقيع
على الوثيقه الخاصه بوقف العدائيات في غرب
دارفور لكن الحاله الانسانيه ما زالت كما
هي عشرات من النازحين داخل الاحياء وفي
الطرقات بعد دمار مراكز الايواء الخاصه
بهم في مدينه الجنينه اما الوضع الانساني
فهو ما زال متردي الوضع الصحي لم يعد حتى
الان للعمل هنالك بعض المراكز عاده للعمل
لكن حتى الان لا تستطيع علاج العدد الكبير
من الجرحى ولا يوجد بها الكوادر الصحيه
وايضا الاجهزه الكافيه لعلاج الجرحى من
الذين اصيبوا في الاشتباك
صالح اسمح لي نتحدث عن مراتب تابعه
للمنظمات دوليه او مراكز محليه
نعم هي مراكز محليه
مستشفى تم تدميره تماما هنالك مراكز مثل
مركز اردا متى وايضا مركز اخر يعمل خلال
الفتره خلال هذه الفتره لكن هذه المراكز
لا تستطيع يعني سد الحوده والفجوه الكبيره
في الصحه لا توجد منظمات حتى الان تعمل
سوى الهلال الاحمر بالتعاون مع الصليب
الاحمر هنالك حركه يومين للهلال الاحمر في
الجنينه حتى الان الهلال الاحمر والصليب
الاحمر فقط ليست لديهم القدره الكافيه
لاحداث فريق كبير في الوضع الصحي الذي
يزداد سوءا يوم بعد يوم خاصه هنالك انتشار
كبير
للجثث داخل الاحياء هذه الهدنه وهذه
الوثيقه التي تم التوقيع عليها يمكن ان
تساهم في الوصول للجرحى
المنازل وايضا للجثث المقدسه في الطرقات
وفي بعض الاحياء في مدينه الجنينه الوثيقه
التي تم التوقيع عليها نصت على فتحه الطرق
بين الجنينه
وهنالك خطوه لعلاج الجرحى في دوله جاد
خاصه بعد الموافقه بعد ما تحدثنا اليهم
قالوا بانهم يبحثون على موافقه ربما يسعون
للتواصل مع الخارجيه السودانيه حتى تتواصل
مع الخارجيه في تشاد بهدف نقل الجرحى
وعلاج الجرحى في التشاد تشاد هي ليست
ببعيده صحيح من الجنينه تبعد حوالي 35
كيلو متر من
عمليات نزوح كبيره
هل لا زالت عمليات النزوح مستمره
وبالمقابل هل هناك من عاد الى بيته يعني
يشعرون بالامان الان بغض الن ظر عن الوضع
الانساني
نعم حالات النزوح كبيره جدا لا توجد عوده
الى المنازل يعني جميع الاحياء الاربعه
التي تمت فيها تمت فيها المعارك الان
خاليه من السكان
جميعهم يتوجهوا الى الاحياء الامنه حتى
الاحياء الامنه يكتظت تماما هنالك من هو
في الطرقات العامه هنالك من هو في
المساجد والمدارس حتى المساجد والمدارس
امتلات تماما بالفارين من القتال في غرب
دارفور بعد ما تحدثنا اليه ووصفوا الوضع
الانساني
بالكارثه خاصه في ظل غياب المياه
والكهرباء في ظل غياب المنظمات التي يمكن
لها المساعده ويمكن لها تحسين الوضع
الغذائي والوضع الصحي في غرب دارفور حتى
الطرقات المؤديه الى الجنينه الان لا
يستطيع احد السفر الى مدينه الجنينه
بالتالي لا يستطيع احد ادخال مواد تموين
او مواد اغاثه
للاهالي هنا
والمواد الموجوده تم نهبها وتم تدمير
السوق وتم تدمير جميع المراكز الحيويه
المتواجده في غرب دارفور من اقليم دارفور
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه شكرا جزيلا لك
هو طبعا مشاهدينا نتابع العواجل سبعه ايام
تبدا خذنا جديده من الخامس من مايو او
بالاحرى من الرابع من مايو اي نتحدث عن
يوم الخميس اذا تمديد لهذه الهدنه
وبالمقابل هناك تصريحات تتحدث عن انه فيما
يبدو هناك اتفاق بين طرفي النزاع للوصول
الى مفاوضات لم يحدد المكان ولكن سيتم
تسميه المبعوثين بهذا الاطار رغم انه
التصريحات السابقه لمبعوث البرهان كان
يتحدث عن رفض لاي شيء يمكن ان يفرض على
الجيش وبالمقابل لا مفاوضات طبعا مع
الدعم السريع على كل قال عضو مجلس السياده
السودان الفريق اول ياسر العطا في تصريحات
خاصه للعربيه الى الجيش يسيطر على السودان
مشيرا الى ان الدعم السريع يحتمي بوجوده
بالاحياء المدنيه المقتضه بالمدنيين وله
قناصه لحمايته متحدثا عن خطط استراتيجيه
للقضاء عليه خلال اسبوعين على حد قوله
كامله على كل ربوع السودان
مدى جيوب غليله في ولايتين اما العاصمه
القوميه والتي تم حجز معظم قوات الخاصه
والاعمال المتمردين فيها فلازلت المعارك
جاهزه وقواتنا المسلحه متوازنه ومتماسكه
تحضر انتصارات متتاليه على العدو المتمرد
التي يحتمي قوات التمرس فهو يحتمل بمنازل
المواطنين المواطنين المدنيين وبعض
المستشفيات وبعض المدارس خاصه في الاحياء
المختصه بالمدنيين ايضا احتمائهم وفي
مناطق فيها منشات حيويه
لا تتعرض للتدمير اي اي ايضا احيانا
يتحركون من مكان لاخر في بسرعه كبيره في
طرق الطرق هي اماكن التي يقضي فيها
المدنيين حاجتهم ومعايشهم وايضا تستخدم
لاجلاء البعثات الاجنبيه
وعلى الاسلحه المنازل في الاحياء المقتظه
بالسكان ايضا يوجد قناصه لحمايتهم عشان
كده التعامل معهم يكون صعب لكن الان هيئه
قياده القوات المسلحه تضع الخطط الكفيله
بتدميرهم نهائيا
طبعا مشاهدينا بالرغم ما تم الاعلان عنه
طبعا والمصدر هو الخارجيه خارجيه جنوب
السودان من انه عمليه التفاوض ممكنه ما
بين حمدتي وايضا البرهان كان العطاء قد
قال للعربيه ان اي وساطه للتفاوض مع الدعم
السريع غير ناجحه وان الجيش يريد اخضاعه
لسلطه الدوله موجها شكره للسعوديه مصر
دوله جنوب السودان على جهودهم انا اشكر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والجمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه وجمهوريه
الجنوب السودان ودول
ومنظمه الايجارات على جهدهم في ذلك الامر
لكن لكن تاكد تمام اخي الكريم ان الوضع
الان هو وضع عمليات البحث
حتى ان ارسل
عدد من الممثلين فلن تنجح اي وساطه لان
الجهد فقط هذا التمرد لسلطه الدوله
قبل ذلك اقترح رئيس الوزراء السودانيه
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لتوفير الاساس
لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى
الاتفاق على انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه
حمدوك اقترح اشراك المدنيين السودانيين في
مفاوضات شامله واستئناف العمليه السياسيه
مؤكدا على ان استمرار الحرب في السودان
وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع قد يضر بالعالم
باسره
على كل من ام درمان تنضم الينا الصحفيه
فاطمه ابراهيم اهلا بك فاطمه بدايه كيف هي
التطورات الميدانيه وهل التصريحات التي
نستمع اليها حول امكانيه التفاوض تنعكس
على الارض او لا
نعم تحيه لك ميسون وكل متابعي شاشه قناه
العربيه اخر التطورات الميدانيه هي عوده
التحليق لطيران الحربي الان ومضادات
الطيران في العاصمه الثلاث وايضا اصوات
للقصف في مدن الخرطوم الثلاث انظر مان
وبحري وايضا الخرطوم الان هناك عدد من
الاشتباكات وتحقيق للطيران في شرق النيل
وسوبا والفتيحات وايضا تم قصف ارتكاز
ارتكازات لقوات الدعم السريع في منطقه ود
البشير هذه المنطقه التي طوال الفتره
السابقه شهد شهدت عدد كبير جدا من
الشباكات اليوم تم
قصف هذا المركز الذي او المنطقه التي
تتمركز بها قوات الدعم السريع فيما يعني
للرجوع
سؤالك ميسون
لا تفاوض لا شراكه مع قوات الدعم السريع
هذا ما ينعكس على الشارع السوداني الان
وايضا عدد من المواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي يتحدثون عن يعني لا يمكن
للتفاوض من جديد مع قوات الدعم السريع
وهذا يتناقد مع ما تم اعلانه من قبل
الخارجيه جنوب السودان تقول انه لا في
تفاوض لم يحدد المكان ولكن سيكون هناك
تسميه لممثلين عن اطراف النزاع وبالتالي
البعض ربما يقول انه هذه الضربات هي
الاخيره ما قبل التهدئه والبعض الاخر ربما
يقول بانها على العكس تناقض تماما هذه
التصريحات ولا تعني
بالحقيقه تهدئه على الارض بغض النظر ان
كان هناك سيكون مفاوضات من عدمه
نعم بالفعل كانت هناك تصريحات من قبل يعني
دوله جنوب السودان الشقيقه وسمي ايضا
بالنسبه لطرفي النزاح كل منهما سمى طرف
يعني يمثله في التفاوض ولكن سرعان ما تم
يعني التراجع عن هذا
صدفه بالفعل يعني الصوت الذي يعلو الان لا
تفاوض في الشارع السوداني ربما الايام
المقبله تتغير الصوره تماما ويعاود
التفاوض ولكن الان يعني يبدو ان ذلك ممكنا
نعوض على الارض طبعا الصراط بعد يوم
الحريه والتغيير نادت لخروج مظاهرات في
المناهق الامنه هل من ردود فعل
نعم بالفعل نادت عن يعني خروجه يعني في
مظاهرات للمواطنين للتنادي بعوده يعني
الحكم المدني ووقف الحرب ولكن ردود
الافعال التي لمستها ميسون الان المواطنون
لا يثقون في اي من القوى السياسيه الان
الموجوده على الارض فبالتالي الان هم فقط
يريدون وقف الحرب ويريدون ايضا يعني عوده
الحياه الى طبيعتها في العاصمه الخرطوم
الان المواطن عام ما عانى من ويلات هذه
الحروب وما زال
يعاني يوما بعد يوم ايضا عدد من
المستشفيات خارجه عن الخدمه انقطاع في
الماء والكهرباء يعني ابسط حقوق الحياه هي
غير متوفره تماما في العاصمه الخرطوم
فبالتالي ليس بمقدار يعني الشعب السوداني
اي يعني سكان مدينه الخرطوم تحديدا يعني
يخرجون مظاهرات في هذا وعلى
التطورات غير امنه نعم من ام درمان
الصحفيه فاطمه ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
وفي تطورات عمليات الاجلاء قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها الجويه قامت
باجلاء اكثر من 200 شخص من الاراضي
السودانيه بناء على قرار الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين مضيفه ان اربع طائرات عسكريه قامت
بعمليات الاجلاء حيث شملت موظفي البعثه
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في السودان والمكاتب
التمثيليه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ولعائلاتهم من مواطن روسيا وبلدان رابطه
الدول المستقله وعدد من الدول الاجنبيه
الصديقه
وفي متابعه للتطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن قال ان 39 مستشفى خرجت
عن الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات مؤكدا
للعربيه ان قوات الدعم السريع حولت بعض
هذه المستشفيات لسكنات عسكريه عبد الرحمن
دعا الى فتح ممرات انسانيه لاغاثه الضحايا
نستمع اليه
مسلسلات التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ صباح
يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه
المستشفيات هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى
تاريخ اليوم مناطق غير امنه هي مستشفيات
التي متاخمه لمناطق الاشتباك شارع الغصر
وشارع
المطار
والقياده والاذاعه ومركز ومركز البحري
مقابل قال سكرتيره ونقابه اطباء السودان
عطيه عبد الله للعربيه قال ان كل
المستشفيات العامه في الخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل بسبب عدم توفر الوقود مشددا ان الحل
الوحيد للوضع الانساني هو وقف القتال حيث
وصف الاوضاع الصحيه بالكارثيه
الاوضاع في الجنينه كارثيه للغايه نعم
النظام الصحي لازال يتهاوى في كل لحظه
وحين بالامس عدد من المستويات خرجت خارج
الخدمه لانه لم نستطيع ايصال طبيه اليها
وبعض الاخر خرج من الخدمه لانقطاع الوقود
الجازلين وايضا هنالك يعني عدد من
الولايات تعاني من نقص في الاكسجين حتى في
ولايه الخرطوم
هذه العوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا ان نحذر
منه من اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى نتيجه
لا نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام الصحيه
نحن نتخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل ما حدث
الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما تخوف عنه
لذلك نحن مطالبه لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل الولايات الخرطوم
هنالك مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها
معينات طبيه
هذا هو مع استمرار المواجهات بات النسوح
هو الحل امام الالاف من السودانيين هربا
من الاقتتال الدائر في هذه الاثناء كشفت
بياناته المنظمه الدوليه للهجره الى نزوح
اكثر من
334 الف شخص داخل السودان منذ بدء
الاشتباكات فيما افدى مسؤول بالامم
المتحده بعبور اكثر من مئه الف شخص حدود
السودان الى دول مجاوره حتى الان مؤكدا ان
الامم المتحده بحاجه لواحد فاصله خمسه
مليار دولار لتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
في السودان لهذا العام
على كل من الخرطوم ينضم الينا شهاب الطيب
المتحدث الرسمي لقوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي اهلا بك سيد شهاب اسمح لي
ان ابدا بتعليقك الاول حول ما نشره ونشرته
خارجيه دوله جنوب السودان فيما يتعلق ان
كان بالمفاوضات او تمديد الهدنه لسبعه
ايام اضافيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اولا طبعا
نحن من خلال قبول هذه الهدن يعني مؤكد كان
سيتم تمديد الهدنه
لوقت اطول يعني تجاوز الاثنين ساعه ونعتقد
انه الان
الطرفين
سواء كان ضغوط داخليه بسبب الاوضاع
الانسانيه المزريه او كان بسبب الضغوط
السياسيه الاخرى التي تضغط على الطرفين او
كان ضغوط اقليميه كان لابد ان يصعب
الطرفين
اتجاه الحوار او التفاوض نعتقد الان
الدعوه
تمت يعني او ما تحدثت به خارجيه جنوب
السودان هو
اتجاه حقيقي تجاه ان تبتدر نقاشه او
مفاوضات رغم انه سيد شهاب لا اعلم الى اي
حتى تعولون بالفعل على انه راح يكون هناك
مفاوضات لانه التصريحات قبل ساعات من الان
كانت تتحدث عن رفض وعمليه اقصاء كامل
للدعم السريع من قبل الجيش ولكن عندي سؤال
فيما يتعلق بالضغوط السياسيه الاقليميه
نعرف عنها ماذا عن الداخل والمكون المدني
الى اي حد استطاع ان يشكل قوى قادره على
التاثير او لا
اولا الحديث عن عن التصريحات هو بس هو
بالف لسؤالك مباشره
التصريحات
الخرجه من القوتين المصارعتين سواء كان من
الفريق ياسر العطاء او كم من بيان الدعم
السريع هي هي دي لغه
الحرب بين العسكريين نعتقد انه يمكن نحن
سودانيين شهيدنا في مفاوضات الاتفاق
السلام الشامل الحرب تستعر في مدينه توريت
وكيف كانت التصريحات المتشدده ولكن كل طرف
يذهب الى المفاوضات اما في بخصوص الحديث
عن ضغوط الاول الجبهه المدنيه لايقاف
الحرب
واستعاده
الديمقراطيه ساعه قوى الحريه والتغيير
مع كثير من الاجسام المدنيه والقاعديه
كليان المقاومه وكانت المبادره من تجمع
الجهل احياء الحاج يوسف وتم اللي هو تكوين
هذه الجبهه الان هي تعمل في في مسارات
انسانيه وفي مسارات سياسيه ولها اتصالات
ونعتقد انه لها خطابات يعني لكثير من
الجهات الممكن تنضم لها وده بيشكل
بالمناسبه
لايقاف الحرب سقط هو يشكل
تعداد لاعداد دور بجبهه متماسكه فيما بعد
ايقاف هذه الحرب من الخرطوم شهاب الطيب
المتحدث الرسمي لقوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي شكرا جزيلا لك
طلعت من البيت كان تقريبا طلعت ما فيش ولا
ركشه ولا مواصله وسيارات تصل بتعدي ما فيش
حدا بيوقف لك وكان ورا البيت فيه زي في
المنطقه الصناعيه محروقه فكان لسه الدخان
شغال فيعني عن جد حسدتي انه يعني رعب هو
كان في الشعور يعني خوف
ورعب يعني انك تشوف جوتك مرميه يمين يسار
والناس مقطعه
والبنوك محروقه يعني بتحس انه خلاص تحصل
في امان نهائي ومستقبل
[موسيقى]
والى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده
ومراسل العربيه هاني صفيان الذي يتابع
المزيد من رحلات المغادره لمن تم اجلائهم
من السودان ليكاني
نعم اهلا بك ميسون واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه اذا من قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه هنا في مدينه جده وما زالت عمليات
الاجلاء من السودان سواء القادمين الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه او كذلك
المغادرين من هذه القاعده بعد عمليات
الاجلاء التي تصل بهم او تكون المحطه
الاخيره او قبل المحطه قبل الاخيره قبل
قبل مغادرتهم الى بلاد هي هذه القاعده وهي
من ضمن المواقع التي حددتها السعوديه الى
جانب الموانئ ايضا هناك ميناء جدا اسلامي
وكذلك من الملك فيصل او قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه طبعا هنا القنصل الباكستاني وكذلك
الممثل قائد قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
وايضا هنا نشاهد في الجنب الاخر او على
يمين المصور هم رعايه باكستان وعددهم 38
طبعا الان اعداد الرعايه الباكستانيه
الذين قدموا او تم اجلائهم من السودان الى
جده او ايضا من الرحلات التي غادرت من
السودان تحديد البورت سودان الى كراتشي
عددهم يتجاوز الالف شخص طبعا فقط قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه قامت باجلاء
ومغادره اكثر من 500 شخص اذا نتحدث عن نصف
عدد رعايه باكستان غادروا من هذه القاعده
وهي قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه هناك
جنسيات ايضا استقبلتها السعوديه وكذلك هذه
القاعده سواء من رعايه الصين والهند وكذلك
من بعثه الامم المتحده وكذلك بعض الجنسيات
مثل رعايه امريكا والمانيا وايضا السويد
وايضا بعض
دول من اوروبا الشماليه عمليه الاجلاء
واضحه جدا لن تنتهي خاصه اذا تحدثنا حتى
هذه اللحظه ان اعداد الرحلات التي تم
تنفيذها عبر هذه القاعده او نفذتها هذه
القاعده سواء عبر طائرات القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه وهي التي تقود مهام
الطائرات العسكريه وكذلك التجاريه تجاوزت
الخمسه وخمسين رحله سواء للرحلات القادمه
من السودان او كذلك المغادره من القاعده
الى بلدان هذه الجنسيات طبعا لا ننسى ايضا
ان هناك خدمات لوجستيه وكذلك خدمات تقدمها
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه من اجل رايه
الجنسيات وكذلك ايضا تسهيل مهمه السفارات
تسهيل مهمه القنصليات وسفرات الدول التي
تقوم بالاهتمام وايضا مغادره رعاياها بكل
يسر وسهوله لعل هذه هي الدفعه الاخيره من
هذه الطائره وهي من نوع سي وان 30 ولو
نشاهده ايضا ونقترب قليلا هذه الطائره هي
من نوع سي ون ثيرتي وهي عسكريه تابعه
للجويه الباكستانيه وتم اختيار هذه
الطائره تحديدا واغلب من يتم او من يتم
اجلاءه من السودان يتم اجراء عبر طائرات
عسكريه تحديدا
وايضا سرعه في الوصول وايضا حتى ايضا سهل
وامانا في عند هبوطها للمدارس سواد في
وادي سيدنا في ام درمان او كذلك في مطار
بورسودان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في جده
[موسيقى]
وهذه وقفه مشاهدينا مع ابرز الاخبار
الدوليه في متابعه لتطورات الاوضاع في
اوكرانيا اعلن قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال اوليكساندارس ريسكي عن
بدء الهجوم المضاد في باخموت ودونيتسكو
وهجوم اجبر القوات الروسيه على التخلي عن
بعض المواقع المسؤول الاوكراني اوضح ان
مجموعه التابعه للجيش الروسي لا تزال
تندفع باستمرار الى المعركه على الرغم من
الخسائر الكبيره في صفوفها مؤكدا ان الوضع
بالقرب من بلده باق موت لا يزال معقدا
للغايه على حد وصفه قبل ذلك اعلن مؤسس
فاغنار
ان قوته تتقدم في بخمت رغم نقص الذخيره
نقلت وكاله التاسع الروسيه عن احد الضباط
الانفصاليين المتقاعدين في لوغانس
كاوندريه ماروتشكو بان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه قد تقوم بحلول نهايه الاسبوع
الحالي بعمليات وصفها بالاستفزازيه خلال
الاحتفالات بمناسبه يوم النصر في روسيا
وذلك عبر استخدام الاسلحه والمعدات التي
زودتها بها دول الناتو ووفقا له فان
القوات الاوكرانيه تستعد عبر تجميع
الوسائل الماديه والتقنيه وايضا تشكيل
المجموعات الضاربه من اجل شن هجوم مضاد
واسع النطاق بحسب تعبيره
هذا واظهرت مقاطع فيديو جنودا اوكرانيين
يتدربون في غابه في منطقه خارتيف الشرقيه
حيث تقول كيف ان الاستعدادات لهجوم المضاد
متوقعه على نطاق واسع ضد قوات موسكو قد
اكتملت تقريبا
[موسيقى]
مزيد ينضم الينا من اكياب مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل اهلا بك حذيفه اخر التطورات
الميدانيه وخاصه تلك المتعلقه بالهجوم
المضاد
مساء الخير ميسون في الحقيقه في اخر 24
ساعه نفذت القوات الروسيه تسعه عشر غاره
ضربه صاروخيه عفوا الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
معظمها كانت في اتجاه
وكذلك في مقاطعه في منطقه
هذه المناطق ايضا كان هنالك تنفيذ لبعض
الضربات الصاروخيه استطاعت القوات الدفاع
الجوي الاوكرانيه ان تسقط خمسه عشر من هذه
الصواريخ ايضا نفذت القوات الروسيه خمسه
عشر غاره جويه وخمسه وعشرين ضربه من انظمه
اطلاق الصواريخ المتعدده دراجه الصواريخ
الوضع بؤره الاعمال العسكريه والقتال
النشط هي مخبوط وكذلك وامريكا هذه المناطق
التي تتركز فيها هجمات القوات الروسيه
طبعا
بحسب تصريح الكسندر سيرسكي والذي تفضلت
قبل قليل وتحدثت عنه طبعا هنالك هجوم مضاد
نفذه في بعض المواقع في
اتجاهاتكا ولكن هذا طبعا يعني هو تحدث عن
هجوم مضاد ولكن هذا لا يفهم منه الهجوم
المضاد بمعناه المنتظر شامل الذي تنوي كيف
تنفيذه تنفيذه نعم صحيح طبعا هل نتوقع
اعلان رسمي حذيفه الطقس
بالتاكيد لا لن يكون هنالك اعلان قبل
الهجوم المضاد الناس سترى فقط هجوما مضاده
بدا بالفعل وهذا طبعا تعلمين ان العمليات
العسكريه تتطلب السريه التامه والمناوره
كذلك تذكرين في العام الماضي عندما بدا
الهجوم المراد كان الهجوم متوقع في خرسور
وبدا فيكي فهذه هذا شيء طبيعي الطقس سيكون
عامل حاسم جدا في عمليه الهجوم المضاده
حتى الان لا يمكن تنفيذ الهجوم المضاد
فعليا لان الامطار ما زالت تهطل في تلك
المنطقه التربه تربه الزراعيه الاراضي
اراضي الزراعيه صينيه لذلك حركه الاليات
والمدرعات ستكون صعبه جدا بمجرد ان يتغير
الجو قد تكون يعني قد يكون هنالك بدايه
لهذا الهجوم المضاد هنالك حشد كبير للقوات
الاوكرانيه حجز للموارد العسكريه حشد
للاليات والمدرعات في هذه المناطق نتحدث
عن الجهه في دنيسك في اتجاه شبه جزيره
القرم وكذلك من اتجاه خاركين في اتجاه ومن
دونست من اتجاه باقي هنالك حج كبير
للموارد العسكريه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ضخموت نفسها الان يعني الالويه
الكتائب المعنيه بالعمل الهندسي تعمل على
شق طرق جديده في المناطق الوعره خاصه بعد
ان اصبح الطريقه الرئيسي
الروسيه ولكن ما زالت طبعا القوات المسلحه
الاوكراني الاوكرانيه تقول انها تسيطر
عليه وانها تستطيع من خلاله ايصال
الامدادات ولكن بشكل ضعيف لذلك هي تعمل
على شخص طرق بديله في تلك الطرق الوعره في
الجهات الاخرى للوصول الى مخبوط الان
الاستراتيجيه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
هي استراتيجيه الدفاعيه بشكل كبير وذلك
لتوفير الذخائر للهجوم المضاد تعلمين ان
الهجوم يستهلك ذخائر اكبر لذلك الان
الاستراتيجيه دفاعيه بامتياز ولكن تحدث في
منطقه واخرى بعض الهجمات لاسترداد بعض
الاراضي طبعا حسب امكانيات المكان والموقع
والمعرفه
العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك
اكد وزير الدفاع الروسي سرغو ان خسائر
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تجاوزت 15 الف
شخص خلال الشهر الماضي واوضح الوزير
الروسي ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه تقوم
بتاديه مهامها بنشاط على طول خط التماس
مؤكدا انها هاجمت بنجاح المستودعات
الاوكرانيه التي تخزن اسلحه غربيه
اكد المستشار الالمانيه ان المانيا لن
تتخذ خطوات احاديه الجانب بشان مساله
امدادات السلاح لاوكرانيا
وقلشولتس ردا على سؤال حول تقديم المساعده
العسكريه لاوكرانيا قال ان بلاده لا تتخذ
خطوات احاديه الجانب وانها تتصرف بالتنسيق
مع الشركاء لضمان عدم حدوث تصعيد بين
موسكو ودول حلف الناتو
هذا وقال الكريم ان نافذه تمديد اتفاق
الحبوب في البحر الاسود تتقلص والمحادثات
الجاريه بين الطرفين مستمره دون تحقيق اي
نتائج ملموسه حيث اكد المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان جزءا من الاتفاق المتعلق بتصدير الحبوب
في الشق المتعلق بمصالح روسيا لم يتم
تنفيذه حتى الان اشارت روسيا الى انها
مستعده للانسحاب من الاتفاق اذا لم تتم
تلبيه مطالبها بتخفيف القيود على صادراتها
الزراعيه
وفي اوكرانيا رجحت مصادر اعلاميه لوكاله
رويترز نقلا عن مسؤول اوكراني رجحت انه من
المقرر ان تجري يوم غد الاربعاء مفاوضات
برعايه امميه حول مبادره البحر الاسود
بمشاركه كافه الاطراف في التفاصيل ذكرت
المصادر نقلا عن المسؤول الاوكراني ذكرت
ان الاتفاق سيسمح بالتصدير الامن للحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر موانئ البحر الاسود
بمشاركه جميع الاطراف وان هناك حاله من
التفاؤل حيال ذلك
قصفت دبابات اسرائيليه مواقع شرقيه غزه في
اطار التوتر بعد وفاه الاسير خضره عدنان
في السجن هذا وطلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من
سكان مستوطنين غلاف غزه بالبقاء في
الملاجئ بعد اطلاق صواريخ من القطاع
اسرائيل قالت انها استهدفت نقاط امن تابعه
لحماس في غزه
هذا وقالت مصادر اسرائيليه انه تم التصدي
لاكثر من 20 صاروخا تم اطلاقها من قطاع
غزه متابع
[تصفيق]
اظهر مسح اجراه المنتدى الاقتصادي
العالميه تساويا في التوقعات حول احتماليه
حدوث او تجنب ركود عالمي خلال العام
الحالي كما استبعد المشاركون في المسح
ظهور تداعيات كبيره على القطاع المصرفي
العالمي جراء ازمه الانهيارات الاخيره
المزيد في هذا التقرير
على الرغم من تحسن توقعات النمو في معظم
الدول الا ان كبار الاقتصاديين لا يزالون
منقسمين بالتساوي وبنسبه 45% بشان حدوث
ركود عالميا ام لا هذا ما ذكره تقرير
توقعات كبار الاقتصاديين 20 23 لمنتدى
الاقتصاد العالمي واوضح التقرير ان
الخبراء يستبعدون اي تداعيات كبيره على
النظام المصرفي باكمله جراء ازمه البنوك
الاخيره لكنهم قلقون بشان حدوث اضطرابات
جديده في المستقبل كما اشار التقرير الى
المخاوف بشان المفاضله بين كبح معدلات
التضخم والحفاظ على النمو الاقتصادي
76% من الخبراء يعتقدون ان البنوك
المركزيه ستجد صعوبه في السيطره على
ارتفاع الاسعار وخاصه في الدول الغربيه
90% من الاقتصاديين يتوقعون تضخما مرتفعا
او مرتفعا للغايه هذا العام في اوروبا في
حين يتوقعوا 68 منهم تضخما في الولايات
المتحده اعلى من المستوى المستهدف اما
بالنسبه للصين فالامر مختلف حيث يتوقع 14%
فقط من الخبراء ارتفاع التضخم في 20 23
تقرير منتدى الاقتصاد العالمي اكد ان
النشاط الاكثر ازدهارا سيكون في اسيا مع
اعاده فتح الاقتصاد الصيني حيث توقع اكثر
من 90% من كبار الاقتصاديين نموا معتدلا
على الاقل في كل من شرق اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ وجنوب اسيا
في اوروبا ما زال ثلاثه ارباع الاقتصاديين
يتوقعون نموا ضعيفا او ضعيفا للغايه العام
الحالي اما في الولايات المتحده كان
الخبراء اكثر تفاؤلا في مارس وابريل مما
كانوا عليه في يناير لكنهم ما زالوا
منقسمين بشان التوقعات بسبب عدم اليقين
المتزايد بشان الاستقرار المالي ومدى
التشديد النقدي من قبل الفيدرالي الامريكي
محمد زهير العربيه
تواصل العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
استعداداتها لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث خلال ايام بقي الملك تشارز واليا
للعهد لسبعين عاما طبعا هي اطول فتره في
تاريخ الملكيه الممتده لاكثر من اربعه
قرون وطيله هذه الفتره اقترن اسمه بزواج
القرن مع الاميره ديانا وعلاقته المتوتره
معها والتي انتهت بطلاقهما قبيله وفاتها
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من لندن المراسل العربيه
مصطفى زارو اهلا بك مصطفى خبرنا عن
الاستعدادات
حقيقه السلطات الامنيه وضعت يعني الكثير
من الحواجز الاسمنتيه والفولاذيه لتكون
ربما العاصمه لندن محصنه من اي وقت مضى
بانتظار هذا التتويج التاريخي الذي
ستستضيفه دير او في وسط لندن القريبه من
البرلمان بالاضافه الى توافد عشرات الالاف
من من عامه الناس بالاضافه الى الضيوف
الدوليين من ملوك ورؤساء ورؤساء وزراء
الدول عده اكثر من 100 دوله ستكون ممثله
في هذا التتويج التاريخي بالاضافه بالطبع
دول الكولونات التي تشارك ايضا في هذا
التتويج عن طريق سواء ممثليها الرسميين او
عن طريق افراد الجيش جيشها يعني هناك ما
يقارب من من اكثر من سته الاف جندي
القطاعات مختلفه من بحريه ومشاه وقوات
السلاح الجو الملكي هذه الترتيبات تم
وضعها وتم ايضا التدريب والتمارين هؤلاء
الذين سيشاركون ويوافقون الملك في موكب
ملكي ابتداء من صباح السبت باتجاه دير
ويسمنتر بالاضافه ان موكب ملكي اخر سيكون
هو اكبر من الموكب الاول عندما يتوج ملكا
اللافت للنظر في هذا التتويج هو انه يمكن
ايضا لعامه الناس بالاضافه الى الحاضرين
وايضا حتى مواطني دول القمر من ان يرددوا
قسم الولاء بعد ان يؤدي الملك تشارلز قسمه
بالله وايضا ايضا كملك للمملكه المتحده
الشماليه بالاضافه الى 14 دوله اخرى في
دول الكومن بالاضافه على على هذا التجويس
سيرافق العديد من
الاحداث سواء في الشوارع العامه او حتى من
قبل
داخل القصر
قصر وينزر حيث
ستستضيف هذا هذه القلعه التاريخيه فريق
غنائهم متنوع يضم العديد من
الفنانين الامريكيين ومحليين للاحتفال
بهذه التتويج وايضا اللافت بان هذا
التتويج سيحمل طابع خاص للملك تشارلز ربما
سنسمع لاول مره يؤدي صلاه بصوت عال على
عكس التقاليد التي رافقت هذه الملكيه ل 10
قرون وبالتالي الكل يتطلع لهذا لهذا اليوم
التاريخي وان يمر بسلام بالرغم من ان هناك
ربما قد تكون بعض الاحتجاجات وخاصه اولئك
الذين لا يدعمون الملكيه من لندن مرا سل
العربيه مصطفى زارو شكرا جزيلا لك
يملك الملك في بريطانيا قيمه رمزيه عاليه
هو على راس الدوله وفقا للدستور البريطاني
غير المكتوب قسم الولاء باسمه وليس باسم
البرلمان النشيد الوطني باسمه وصورته على
العمله والطوابع البريديه مع ذلك فهو لا
يحكم وايضا لا يشارك في الانتخابات بل
يتعرض لانتقادات ان حاول ان يبدي رايه في
الحياه السياسيه في البلاد نتابع
[موسيقى]
الملك تشارز الثالث هو اعلى سلطه في
المملكه المتحده وايرلندا الشماليه يتمتع
بصلاحيات ملكيه ينص عليها الدستور
البريطاني غير المكتوب ولكن السلطات الملك
في الحاضر رمزيه وبروتوكوليه
للملك عدد من الوظائف ذات طابع سياسي من
تعيين رئيس وزراءها حصل حزبه على اكبر عدد
من مقاعد البرلمان لتشكيل حكومه جديده الى
افتتاح البرلمان الرسمي في احتفال تقليدي
يلقي فيه خطابا من كرسي العرش في مجلس
اللوردات خطاب يتضمن برنامج الحكومه في
الدوره البرلمانيه الجديده يلتقي كذلك
وزير الخزانه سنويا قبل تقديم الموازنه
للعموم كما يقوم الملك ايضا بحل البرلمان
قبل اجراءات انتخابات عامه
من مهام الملكه ايضا المصادقه على مشاريع
القوانين التي يقر البرلمان قبل ان تصبح
قانونا ونظريا يمكن للملك رفض الموافقه
على القوانين لكن المره الاخيره التي
استخدم فيها ملك بريطانيا هذا الحق كانت
قبل ثلاثه قرون وكان ذلك في عهد الملكه ان
اسبوعيا يلتقي الملك برئيس الحكومه
للاطلاع على برامجها كما يتراس اجتماعات
شهريه لمجلس الملك الخاص ويقوم بمجموعه من
التعيينات بناء على التوصيات حكومته
يستضيف الملك رؤساءه وممثل الدول الزائرين
ويقبل اعتمادات السفراء الاجانب وتشارز
الثالث هو ايضا اعلى سلطه في اربع عشره
دوله اخرى في دول الكومنواز
الملك تشارز الثالث يسود ولا يحكم هو رمز
الهويه الوطنيه والوحده والشعور
بالاستقرار والاستمراريه الكثير من
صلاحيته قل استخدامها مع مرور الزمن ولو
ان وجودها يعتبر امرا مهما في النظام
الملكي الدستوري السائدي في بريطانيا
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني فوميوكشيدا انه
يعتزم زياره كوريا الجنوبيه الاسبوع
المقبل لاجراء محادثات مع الرئيس سينسول
وبحث سبل تحسين العلاقات بين البلدين حيث
ستتركز جهود الطرفين على انهاء الخلافات
القائمه وعلى تشكيل جبهه موحده ضد
التحديات الاقليميه بما في ذلك كوريا
الشماليه ستكون هذه اول زياره يقوم بها
رئيس وزراء ياباني للبلاد منذ 2018 وتاتي
بعد اتفاق بين الطرفين على انهاء القيود
التجاريه التي كانت قائمه
استقبل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن نظيره
الفلبيني في البيت الابيض حيث تصدرت
مباحثاتهما قضيه توسع بكين على طرق
التجاره الدوليه والجزر الاستراتيجيه في
بحر جنوب الصين نتابعه
تذكر الولايات المتحده ايضا وبشده انها
ستظل صارمه في التزامها بالدفاع عن
الفلبين بما في ذلك بحر الصين الجنوبي
وسنواصل دعم التحديث العسكري للفلبين
يقوم المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لليمن يتم
بجوله خاصه لدول الخليج لتعزيز الجهود
المشتركه وايضا التواصل لاتفاق جديد
لعمليه السلام حيث سيجتمعوا بممثلين
سعوديين وعمانيين ويمنيين لمناقشه الجهود
الحاليه والعمل على هدنه الامم المتحده
التي اتاحت اطول فتره هدوء في اليمن منذ
بدء الحرب
قال الجيش الباكستاني ان قوات الامن داهمت
مخباين لمسلحين على طول الحدود مع
افغانستان قاده الاشتباكات عنيفه اسفرت عن
مقتل ثلاثه مسلحين ذكر الجيش في بيان ان
مسلحين اصيب ايضا في مداهمات شبه متزامنه
طبعا في مدينه دير اسماعيل خان باقليم
متاخم لافغانستان
وصلنا مشاهدينا الى نهايه هذه الساعه
الاخباريه ولكن التغطيه مستمره على راس
الساعه مع ميسون واحد مشاهدينا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات